nein kommt rein freunde ist ein
großartiger tag für uns dave und ich
haben unser büro als so weit erklärt
dass wir es euch zeigen können es gibt
heute eine bürotür hätte auch nicht
gedacht dass ich das mache aber ich habe
wirklich diesen ort hier so krank in
mein herz geschlossen haben so viel zeit
rein gesteckt dass ich ihn habe ich
einfach nicht vorenthalten wollte
wir sind hier im studioraum es gibt zwei
räume einfach nur bei uns groß ist sehr
bescheiden das studium und das büro also
haben wir die beiden räume genannt
gefreut dass das studio hier wird
gedreht vor allem von day4 könnte ja mal
hier über schauen dann seht ihr schon
den klassischen hintergrund aus
jeglichen hits von dave wie zb vor allem
zur rolex hoch traden ps möglich
ihr kennt es mittlerweile ja es ist sehr
sehr viel was man erklären kann
natürlich für die couch kommt aus dave
wohnung
man muss dazu sagen wir haben nicht
ultra viel kohle in die hand genommen
jeder youtuber der so natur macht nennt
sein video irgendwie meinen 250.000 euro
büro oder meint 80.000 euro gaming
zimmer
wir haben schon viel kohle hier
reingesteckt sind aber trotzdem
unfassbar herr pieth mit dem ergebnis
und ich gerne mal ein bisschen auf alles
an also tier couch aus dave büro dann
haben wir pflanzen irgendwie steine
erzeugt euro 20 euro ist einfach geil
für das bild macht auch ein bisschen was
für den ton ton war es auch wichtig wie
man vielleicht schon leicht erahnen kann
aber ansonsten haben wir hier ein
absolut leeres regal ob dem einfach nach
oben braucht rops chips stehen
wir haben hier so phillips jubel über
das war auch ein thema was mir sehr am
herzen lag
ich habe sehr viel zeit in smart büro
nicht smart home investiert hazy licht
im studio grün
es ist der reinste traum jetzt schon
gehört hey siri also haben das ganze auf
home board basiert geht ein bisschen ins
detail ich weiß dass interessiert
wahrscheinlich jeden gast wir machen
auch für diejenigen von euch die kochen
lieben und mich wegen kochen schauen
eine kleine verköstigung tonnen
schärfsten rahmen die wir finden konnten
wir euch eine kleine küche ja gleich ja
auch ein 12 video schon was
ich verkaufe hier zur nächsten wand wir
uns gedacht jede wand sollte irgendwie
einen hintergrund abständen ein studio
hintergrund dass gerade eben ist der
klassische dave hintergrund das hier ist
ja eher so eine so eine akustik tech
review geschichte die wir noch nicht
viel benutzt haben das haben wir aber
auch erst seit die lange in ammerthal
wochen seit anderthalb wochen wollen wir
das ding hier wo das ultra krass ich
weiß nicht ob man das also erstens alles
ist auch wollen das war uns sehr wichtig
das ist so ein höhenverstellbarer tisch
wir haben alles auf wollen gepackt weil
wir wollen halt wirklich dynamisch und
flexibel sein
ich habe ja auch langfristig nicht vor
nur koch videos zu machen sondern ich
möchte vielleicht auch noch mal mit ein
bisschen anderen videos ein comeback
starten aber erstmal ist natürlich
kochen da das denken übrigens bock macht
merkt ihr ein unterschied wenn ich hier
direkt rein rede ich weiß es nicht ich
hoffe es ist auf jeden fall sehr krasse
diese dinger haben wir auch an den
decken
das hier sind so hexagone oben haben wir
ein bisschen größere dinge macht ultra
viel an der raumakustik sehr kraft also
ist einfach keinen halt davor war das
nicht das aller greifen jetzt aber
kommen wir zum nächsten mal
es ist eine band die einen sehr großen
stil an sich trägt zwar kein zufall da
war eine schrauben hämmern spiegel
hallo auch zu sehen
hier ist ein motorrad ständer klar man
sich's gehört unser büro ist im
erdgeschoss dementsprechend hat dave ja
auch schon mal sein motorrad
reingefahren
das hier ist eine unserer neuesten
errungenschaften es sollte vielleicht
langfristig dave ist ja auch ein
ein passionierter streamer und unser
traum ist man ein bisschen der zukunft
ist dass wir hier einfach ein komplettes
streaming setup an die wand knallen
riesenfernseher kamera alles mögliche
playstation suite und dann kann man
einfach wenn man irgendwie vor einem
schwarzen hintergrund drehen will oder
ist einfach nicht im raum handelt darauf
ist ein studio vorhang hat auch wieder
die konstruktion irgendwie 100 euro
gekostet wir haben uns ein paar smarte
ideen überlegt wie wir hier ja unser
büro studium mäßig gestalten können für
für die für das kleine welt hier auch
nochmal probst an seit für die streich
technik wir haben einfach als wir das
büro übernommen
das sei übrigens vorher so aus und mein
gott das ist wirklich schlimm aus als
erst übernommen haben wir alles genau so
werden keinen bock zu streichen dann
haben wir hier an der wand auch sehr
gerne auch einen richtigen cayston
eiszeit studio flair aber so klappt
spieler kann man da ziehen alle slots
sponsor qualität unsere wasser ecke
jetzt trinken wir natürlich nur wasser
dave hat überhaupt keinen zucker problem
ihr seht ihr vorher einen luftreiniger
das ist echt eine ganz nette geschichte
der ist sehr groß kann beide räume
befeuern sag ich mal und zwar ist die
luftreiniger fonds eco tec sowie ein
paar andere kleine gadgets die wir hier
im büro man aber wir schauen uns jetzt
erst mal vor wir darauf weiterhin das
herzstück an das büro das büro im büro
vom rhein
ich muss erstmal eine größte
errungenschaft noch mitnehmen ja eine
150 watt leuchte auf rollen mit riesiger
softbox die es uns ermöglicht die beste
qualität für euch zum und was auch über
das gleis das war schon drin diese
kranke zürich will das gibt dem ganzen
noch mal so heftigen weit irgendwie das
hat schon so ein bisschen so ein
lifestyle keine ahnung ich feiere das
richtig kraft und wirklich wir wollten
wie gesagt alles auf rollen packen also
geboren komme ich du plötzlich perfekt
ausgeleuchtet ja es ist sehr sehr
gemütlich hier soviel kann man schon mal
sagen auch hier der ton einfach wieder
unglaublich kurz mal in die decke
wir haben wieder verschiedene base sind
das passt raps nicht ganz aber könnte
man sagen welche schaldinger wieder
aufgegangen über der tür auf
muster angeordnet sieht wieder meist aus
hat aber keine kohle gekostet es wird
auch teuer aber wir haben nicht super
viel geld in die hand und haben auf
jeden fall
man muss ja dazu sagen erst seit sechs
monaten oder so sind dave endlich so
richtig im game wieder na also davor
habe ich nichts gemacht und dave hatte
noch nicht richtig angefangen das heißt
wir haben wirklich ja also von null
angefangen ist natürlich deutlich zu
viel gesagt aber wir uns wirklich wieder
rein gefuchst und dementsprechend
wollten wir jetzt auch nicht ultra viel
geld in die hand nehmen direkt aber es
ist glaube ich geiler geworden als
geworden wenn wir halt irgendwie keine
ahnung jemanden beauftragt hätten und
super league oder in die hand genommen
hätten
meine wand vom büro also hier steht man
spart bestand days ist sehr klein
gehalten
wir haben hier also eine kommune geben
wir vor unterlage lagert ordner wie auch
immer
drucker alles clean weiß gehalten das
hier ist der luxus spiegel so wenn ich
den gerne
der ist nämlich rein für die optik klar
wenn man sich da vorstellen auch wenn
man groß ist wie ich kann man einfach
nur seinen kopf sehen und nichts anderes
also es ist albern aber ich fand dass da
so ein nackter punkt dann haben wir den
spielraum gekleidet übrigens alles ist
von den tieren also wirklich sucht nicht
nach exotischen möbeln oder so hier die
wand der idee die vor allem von dave
genutzt wird darf man davon alles sehen
ja ich fühle mich so ein bisschen nicht
pause macht mir jetzt dann hier ein
klassischer dx race hat er schon ewig
alt guckt nicht zu genau hin
den habe ich luca führen vor wie
abgekauft 2017 oder so und seitdem
begleitet er mich dann hier equipment
wartet wir dachten uns möglichst wenig
zeigt warum stehen hier sollte immer
alles beweglich sein und so dann haben
wir uns einfach diese lok platten geholt
keinen kopfhörer die sehr sehr teuer
waren und das geld eigentlich nicht wert
sind keine also wieder irgendwelche
sachen aufgehangen die jungen die cool
aussehen und halbwegs funktionalität
haben ja dann kommen wir auch schon zum
schreibtisch setup und ich muss wirklich
sagen guckt es euch einfach mal schaut
einfach mal auf diesen tisch ignoriert
den staub der mann vielleicht sehen kann
es ist ultra clean finde ich ich habe
wenn ihr genau hinsieht keine maus ich
benutze einfach keine maus ich arbeite
nur mit trackpad ich habe mir das du
angeboten weil wenn ich mobil an meinem
laptop arbeitet wenig damit er genau so
schnell wie wenn ich hier vom pc sitze
und funktioniert super gut schneidet ihr
alle meine videos kommt er selbst und
dementsprechend war mir dieses setup
gewichtig monitor ist so ein lg fock hey
widescreen den ich je bekommen habe
irgendwie stadt eine stadt 1600 euro
welche in lübeck gezogen habe der fall
auch eingeholt sein aber kaum fotos
heißt ich habe diesen traumhaft monitors
etwa auf demselben weg sehen werdet
lampe kann sonst muss man nicht viel
wissen und sehr richtig man benutzt ist
kein einziges mal ehrlich zu sein man
kann einfach den schreibtisch hochfahren
ich sage immer dass ich das gerne
benutzt wenn ich irgendwie ein video
schnell fertig machen muss weil dann
kann ich nicht mehr so zählen auf meinem
stuhl entsteht hier der beste kanal auf
youtube
dicht gefolgt von dave natürlich hier
seit neuestem mit neuem namen leute
jagst vielleicht gesehen ich habe mich
von krankhafter getrennt ich mag es
passt einfach besser zum kochen und ich
mache erst 2016 keine minecraft videos
mehr pcs haben wir auch dran geklatscht
ist aber auch so eine kleine sachen kann
man auch um zu schieben ist natürlich
gut für sichtschutz und wie gesagt im
erdgeschoss auf den leuten sagen
also brauchen nicht dass er über verein
geguckt werden kann
liebe ich sehr unsere hänge pflanze und
dann kommen wir auch schon zu dave seite
wir sind auf der seite angekommen sie
sieht sehr sehr wild aus muss ich sagen
ich habe am anfang schere stein papier
gespielt der platz hat mehr fenster der
platz mehr platz und ich glaube am ende
haben wir beide ein gutes los gezogen
als ich ein bisschen mehr licht dave hat
dafür diese ultra kranke equipment ecke
dass so ein bisschen inspired von casey
leistet der kanal festlichen kennt
hoffentlich in seinem
büro alles an den wänden hängen hat und
es ist ja ein passionierter fotograf ist
schon zwei mal gesagt ist das wort nur
noch halb so cool objektive kameras und
hier sehr viele sachen die man unbedingt
an equipment band haben muss wenn man
schnell was haben wir direkt los haben
es geht dabei überhaupt nicht darum dass
einfach nur was da hängt und cool
aussieht aber das wird natürlich nach
und nach mit funktionalität verfügt dann
hier eine wand das war auch ein
geniestreich von uns auch über ultra
schiebt das ist dort mit schall
verbessern
hintendran und man kann als sachen dran
bin wir haben so eine collage gemacht
dave ist ja auch mit einer eigenen marke
unterwegs unter anderem und da ist
natürlich immer so ein bisschen
inspirationen wünschenswert dann haben
wir hier oben zwei kabel die von einem
server den wir in unserem bad stehen
haben glaube ich jeder mensch würde uns
umbringen dafür dass wir gegen feucht um
den server lager
da kommen zwei karls unserem server über
die haben ja auch extra so in your face
mäßig verlegt ist auch wieder eine heiße
geschichte ich finde das nicht super gut
aus dann kommen wir zu einem kleinen
reich twitter küche auch hier haben wir
nichts neu gekauft diese küche stand
schon drin aber wir haben quasi jegliche
funktionalität hinzugefügt da kommt der
nächste unterstützer ins spiel klar
stein
die haben so ein paar kleine sachen fürs
büro zur verfügung gestellt das ist ein
induktionsherd platte übels übels
kompakt perfekt für unser büro habe so
ein spritzschutz hinter gestellt oben
einfach was man halt so braucht
bretter messer toaster kaffeemaschine
auch wieder von klar stein wasserkocher
kartoffelpuffern also wir haben 50 euro
basic ikeas essen kochen gold und es
reicht vollkommen aus weil wir in der
regel lieferando auseinandernehmen ihrem
büro ein absolut praktisch das regal was
auch drin waren irgendwie beibehalten
und jetzt hier der nächste traum
sie können mich wahrscheinlich schon
nicht mehr sehen es ist eine green wall
das war als lästig sind so 25 x 25 cm
und musste alle aneinander knüpfen die
logischerweise feld pflanzen aber ich
finde sie sehen über sky laut eben auch
ein bisschen zur akustik
sind einfach live um so ein bisschen
grün im augenwinkel zu haben wenn man
hier drüben steht wir sind schon relativ
weit mit unserer tour
ich möchte dir echt mal mich bei einem
weiteren unterstützern bedanken und zwar
wie gesagt smartphone war mir sehr
wichtig und der dritte und letzte
unterstützung ist tabu
ihr seht vielleicht hier unten dieses
sehr schmucken thermostat ich fand
einfach smartphone muss so ach da kann
ich auch noch ganz kurz auf lang ihr
noch mal ganz kurz zurück dieses brett
hier oben wir waren auch ein bisschen
faul werden sehr viel improvisiert haben
wir einfach mal ohne dübel in die wand
geschraubt und und das smartphone system
hat auch eine überwachung hey siri licht
im büro orange grün unser smartphone
system hat auch mit kleinem
überwachungskamera und wird dann direkt
mal unseren feld mitgenommen denen wir
hatten als wir das installiert haben war
sehr lustig gucken wir dann auch in den
letzten raum der für mich persönlich ein
absolutes highlight ist wo ich auf
einmal einen major schau dort geben muss
an coco an swarovski bernasconi leute
die in köln einen sehr sehr guten
tätowierer suchen checkt den 80 habt ihn
und viele weitere sachen unten verlinkt
es ist eigentlich nur sabbath aber ich
finde seine arbeit hat das zu einem
absoluten highlight gemacht gucken sie
mal rein
also ihr seht vielleicht der ton wird
instant schlecht ihr merkt wie gut wir
den toren in den anderen räumen
gestaltet haben graffiti an der wand wir
hatten so eine grobe vorstellung der
hergekommen und haben wirklich was wie
ich finde eine üble sache auf der haut
so ein abstraktes kunstwerk einfach was
ich über die gesamte band erschreckt der
raum ist relativ schmal wir probieren
mit bibo ein bisschen was zu zeigen dass
man das gut sehen kann auch hier
natürlich wieder casey temperatur in bar
auf 24 grad
unnötige kleine spielereien dem auch so
thür fensterkontakte fenster geht auf
zeitung geht aus so ganz nette
geschichten und ich bin wie gesagt ein
großer fan des hat werde ich das auch
wahrscheinlich mit der zeit noch ein
bisschen ausführlicher gestalten was
soll man sagen spiegel
der raum ist willig sehr klein kleines
fenster hier drüben haben wir unseren
schrank in dem wir so sachen abstellen
und oben drin ist unser professioneller
server ich glaube wenn man das durch für
sage ich bereite schnell die speichen
rahmen zu und bei einem resümee bei dem
wir uns den mund wegbrennen hört ihn an
die letzten gedanken wie verfahre ich
habe mich die schärfsten rahmen würden
die es im supermarkt ab zubereitet babys
jetzt auch mit vor der kamera vielleicht
noch mal ein zwei worte zum beruf er ist
ein absoluter traum
es gibt noch ein paar kleinigkeiten zu
regeln aber den großteil haben wir auf
jeden fall gemacht
trotz dessen dass wir nicht so tausende
von euros ausgegeben haben finde ich ist
das schönste büro von allen nicht so der
typ gesehen habt klage hat nach unserem
spiel ein gericht aber es ist schon das
gratis tool gibt es ruhig zu
ja gerade weil wir so wenig ausgegeben
haben wir fühlen uns sowohl sind jeden
tag hier sieben tage die woche war sich
frosta ist der absolute traum ich würde
sagen es gibt drei gründe die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass ich auf youtube
wieder durch ziert das ist zum einen bin
ich selbst so muss man sagen dass ich
habe endlich mal ein arsch hochbekommen
zum anderen ist das dave wir sitzen hier
motivieren uns gegenseitig profitieren
voneinander einfach geil und drittens
ist das beruf wirklich die drei sachen
ultra wichtig und jetzt lasst das fresh
blood weg drin sind von krasser hätte
ich jetzt schon gut auf wäre es auch
schon mal schafft geholt aber diesem
sehr kraft ich habe zwei sachen nicht
erwähnt saugroboter von zecotek und
fensterputzer robotern haben wir einmal
laufen lassen ist den abbruch
also wir werden natürlich trotzdem
weiter benutzen irgendwann nochmal aber
man sehe auch rücksichtsvoll sonst werde
ich alles gesehen das ist unser traum
büro dir sterben jetzt ein bisschen
weiter früher wäre das ein ganzer upload
gewesen dessen geschäft einen rahmen
würden jetzt zum auto und
was gut besser dass es nicht so ist